étranger
nous sommes tous assis depuis le matin personne ne
vois-tu personne autour personne il
n'y a aucun client ils n'ont pas acheté ils se
plaignent du manque d'argent l'argent
n'est pas dans la ville
[Musique]
étranger
aucun client ne vient
mais  ils ont préféré avoir de l'argent liquide et il
n'y a pas d'argent liquide
et c'est tout le sans argent liquide Écrasez
tout ce que nous avons juste du mal, juste du
mal à lutter, nous pouvons voir
que c'est douloureux parce que nous n'avons pas vu mon
client universitaire, personne n'entre sur
le marché pour fixer le prix ou pour acheter sans espèces.  je
me sens mal oui je me sens mal je ressens des douleurs
avec les larmes du Christ beaucoup de gens pleurent
il n'y a pas d'argent les gens meurent les
gens ont du mal à chercher de l'
argent mais où est l'argent
[Musique]
vois le prix est élevé et qui d'autre  nous
leur disons que ce que nous achetons au marché,
nous allons l'acheter parce que
les choses qui sont chères au marché sont trop chères, donc tous,
quand ils mangent,
ils nous supplient de réduire le prix,
il n'y a pas de feu, il n'y a aucune faute à acheter
ça vient pour ton véhicule maintenant tu
sais que son essence est trop chère donc tu
sais que ça rend tout serré
sans que je vois qu'il y a de
la violence dans ce pays
pour le Nigeria
[Musique]
tu ne verras pas d'argent pour attirer des étrangers